CBS News has learned authorities in
Pennsylvania have reopened an
investigation into sexual abuse claims
made against a Catholic priest now this
comes as Pope Francis faces calls to
resign over a claim that he knew about
alleged sex abuse by a former American
Cardinal and allowed him to serve
unpunished
a grand jury report released this month
identified hundreds of abusive priests
and more than a thousand child victims
across Pennsylvania Nicky batiste has
been following this story and shows us
the efforts to bring some alleged
predators to justice Nicky good morning
good morning over the past few weeks
we've spoken with many alleged victims
who as adults came to grips with what
they say happen to them as children
almost all report they were blocked from
getting justice because the statute of
limitations had expired now CBS News has
learned at least one decades-old case is
reopened in Pennsylvania it started you
know you know running up to his place
and you know some alcohol and then dirty
movies it just went from there
grooming you yeah basically that's how
II D Roger says his abuse began in the
late 1980s he brought us to the grounds
of his former Catholic high school you
know they didn't want to do anything
about it where he described how he
claims the principal father Desmond
McGee raped him repeatedly for years you
know when it's finished you know good
boy you know let's go he said good boy
oh yeah he's a good boy I had to do my
confessionals right to him he reported
the abuse to the Diocese of Erie in 1990
around the time McGee expelled him
blaming a poor attendance record and
academic deficiencies I think it's
disgusting what they did and what they
covered up and I don't know how else to
look at it did you ever have any
disciplinary problems or anything and no
no nothing like that I mean I wasn't
great grades but I was a seer above you
couldn't play sports if you're under a C
average in a phone call from his nursing
home McGee told CBS News it's not true I
did not abuse anybody former bishop
Donald Troutman says he did learn of the
allegations until nine
96 in a statement Troutman claims he
notified law enforcement and says the
church investigated the allegations and
found them not to be substantiated I'm
wore this since I was 17 since the abuse
ended yep after we spoke with Rogers CBS
News learned police have reopened the
investigation into his claims at the
request of the District Attorney a
police report from the time shows
prosecutors determined the statute of
limitations had run out on the reported
sexual assaults and a judge in 1997
concluded the statute of limitations had
run out for a civil lawsuit the Church
soon after promoted McGee to Monsignor
what's your reaction when you learned
there's a law that protects the man you
say raped you angry disappointed I
actually surprised too
Pennsylvania's behind the curve Marcie
Hamilton is a University of Pennsylvania
professor she says some 41 states have
eliminated the statute of limitations
for at least some child sex abuse
charges there are efforts underway in
Pennsylvania to do the same for now
Hamilton says she believes prosecutors
could still pursue other options like
child endangerment charges against some
church officials the secrets were being
kept children were being endangered and
the hierarchy was well aware of it I
think those claims actually have real
possibilities Maggie's name is not among
the more than 300 predator priests
identified in a recent grand jury report
but in general the report notes there
may be more indictments in the future as
the investigation continues
for you what does justice look like
McGee in prison with handcuffs and I
don't even think they'll be closed
closure then but it would be a little
bit of redemption maybe you know but I
don't think I could ever get closure
bishop Troutman's name appeared numerous
times in the grand jury report for
allegedly concealing other claims of
abuse
Troutman who's now retired denies all
allegations of any cover-ups a lawyer
for the Erie diocese says it will
continue to fully cooperate
with any law enforcement investigations
these are tough stories to hear they are
and we're going to talk more about it
with the Pennsylvania Attorney General
later thanks so much Nikki